Imagine you're going on the Internet and reaching
a Web portal, such as gmail, let's say,
for accessing your email. In fact, while you're
doing this, a million other clients are doing
exactly the same thing, trying to reach the
web portal through the IP network. The service
that you're trying to reach may be architected
to direct your particular request to a specific site.
And the architecture within that site may look like this, a whole bunch of
servers, maybe on the order of thousands
or even 10,000, within a cold dark room,
interconnected to one another through perhaps a
high bandwidth communication backplane. And also all of
the servers are connected to data stores
for processing requests that may be coming in.
And the servers may optionally use a backplane that allows them to talk to one
another for servicing any particular request. Any of the servers may be able to
handle an incoming client request. Now in
the generic picture that I'm showing you here,
the load manager that is sitting in
between these servers, and the IP network redirects
an incoming client's request to one the
servers. The chosen server may than process the
query and answer the client. The role of
the load manager is to balance the client
traffic among all the servers. Basically, the load
manager has to make sure that no particular
server is overloaded. One of the characteristics of
most of the giant scale services is that
the these client requests that are coming in are
all independent of one another. Sometimes, this also called
embarrassingly parallel, meaning that all of these client requests
can be handled in parallel. So long as it is
enough server capacity to meet all the incoming requests.
So the rule of the load manager is to
balance the client traffic and redirect them to the
server so that no particular server is overloaded and all
of the servers get equally utilized in
servicing incoming requests. The other responsibility of
the load manager is to hide partial
failures. Because when we're talking about the
scale of giant scale services, and the
kind of computational power that resides in
the data center for servicing these giant
scale services, they're humongous, they're 10,000 nodes.
And when you have so many nodes, compute nodes and data nodes and so on, it's
not a question of if something will fail,
but is a question of when something is going
to fail. So the load manager has to make sure that it is observing the state
of the servers and insuring that the incoming
client requests are shielded from any such failures that
may happen internally, within a particular site.